bullins christmas markets are back in
business after closing in the wake of
Monday's attack the owners of the stalls
on Alexander Platz a different market to
where the attack took place want to sell
as much of their stock as they can once
again Berliners and tourists are
strolling through the markets looking
for Christmas treats but emotions are
still running high no sewing bassoon I
have mixed feelings I'm happy to come to
work but I also feel a little uneasy but
I'll make the best of it you have to
keep your chin up you can't run and hide
that's all I might just live normally
you ride the subway and go to concerts
and you go to work as always it's always
and so on cars movies sure I'm a little
uneasy but do I need to live in fear I
don't think so so I'm just carrying on
and mourning for the people directly
affected by this it's tragic
police have stepped up security sending
out both uniformed and plainclothes
officers to patrol the area many
tourists have come to Berlin especially
to get a taste of the typical German
Advent season does why we came so this
is kind of we want to celebrate with
everyone we want to keep it going we
think that's what everyone should do as
well kind of keep going yeah for sure
yeah we will live our lives in the
proper way we live our lives properly
and we're not going to be frightened
away by by terror if I see and police
and something like this I scared a
little but I feel very good deal two
days after the shocking attack many here
are determined to stay true to the
holiday spirit and they refused to give
in to fear for insulting cow we can't
let idiots like that make us give up our
freedoms given the for your eyes of a
dire standards but go anyway to vote him
on his mom I think a lot of people are
feeling defiant I'm sure if you will
choose to stay at home but I think a lot
of people are saying now more than ever
but all the attempts to return to normal
can't hide the fact that the attack in
Germany's capital city has left its mark
including on this Christmas market on
Alexander Platz